if you're completely lost yep four pawns  down like one one Pawn back but now  white wins a different one and the Rooks  are both coming to the seventh rank we  call them the blind pigs they'll just  devour anything in their path and uh one  is gonna come right now  there's gonna be two Rooks along the  seventh row do you think we're gonna see  a resignation  soon Shaq looks in pain there we go  the problem is the black Bishop can't  move if it does the white Rook will  slide behind the black king checkmate  yep the computer says plus 13 this one  is not going to last too much longer I  think we'll see Shaq resign and uh yeah  we have it we have it we have the result  oh it's over a loss in game four and  also a loss in the match for Mohamed  Yara of oh he doesn't look happy and so  it doesn't young Crystal do that but he  must be happy inside because a match win  in the first uh match here in the final  is very good news for young Crystal